les remplacements se succèdent à la tête
du commandement de l'offensive russe en
Ukraine cette fois c'est le chef
d'état-major des armées lui-même qui est
nommé Valérie guerracimov le ministère
russe de la Défense en dévoile les
raisons officielles dans un communiqué
la hausse du niveau de commandement de
l'opération spéciale est lié à un
élargissement de l'ampleur des missions
accomplir à la nécessité de mener une
interaction plus étroite entre les
composantes des forces armées Valérie
guerassimov remplace Sergueï surovikin
il n'aura dirigé les opérations qu'à
peine trois mois il est d'ailleurs
rétrogradé adjoint de Valérie
guerracimov aux côtés de deux autres
généraux Sergueï soroviki avait
notamment proposé et superviser le
retrait russe de la ville de Kerson
début novembre un revers majeur pour le
Kremlin son remplacement intervient
aussi après la frappe sur la ville de
makifka qui a fait 89 morts parmi les
soldats russes le bilan le plus
meurtrier côté russe que Moscou est
reconnu à ce jour l'arrivée de Valérie
guerassimov pourrait aussi s'expliquer
par une volonté de passer à la vitesse
supérieure dans cette guerre
à moins qu'il soit déchargé de son poste
de chef d'état-major des armées c'est
celui qui dispose de la totalité des
moyens de l'armée russe ça veut dire que
sidéra simov est nommé comme commandant
des opérations en Ukraine c'est qu'on
est beaucoup plus proche de la forme de
la guerre reconnue comme tel par les
Russes et donc de la capacité d'employer
un maximum de moyens de l'armée russe en
Ukraine c'est donner à mon avis le
signal
d'un durcissement net de la Russie dans
ce dans ce conflit face à cette
perspective l'Ukraine de son côté
réitère ses appels aux occidentaux pour
obtenir des armements lourds et de
longue portée